So now let's try our hand
at the moesi protocol.
Suppose we have three cores
maintain moesi coherence.
And the variable x starts
out by only being in memory.
So it's not in any of the caches.
So we have our three cores C0,
C1 and C2.
And the first access that
happens is read x on core zero.
What is the new state of this block in
the cache that belongs to this core?
Next C1 does read X, what is the new
state of the block on this core and
what is the state of this block on
C0 after C1 is done with this read?
Now C2 does read x.
What is it's new state for this block?
And what is the new state of
this block in C1's cache?
Or does it just stay the same?
And finally C1 there's a write to x.
What is the new state of
the block in C1's cache?
In C2's cache?
And in the cache of core C0.